♪ ♪
>> Jesse: THE WHITE HOUSE IS
BLASTING THE MEDIA SAYING THAT
THEY TOOK THE PRESIDENT OUT OF
CONTEXT.
OVER TRUMP’S COMMENTS ABOUT
HEAT, LIGHT, AND DISINFECTANT.
HERE’S WHAT HE SAID.
>> SO, SUPPOSING WE HIT THE BODY
WITH A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF,
WHETHER IT IS ULTRAVIOLET OR A
REALLY POWERFUL LIGHT, AND I
THINK YOU SAID THAT HAS NOT BEEN
CHECKED, BUT YOU’RE GOING TO
TEST IT.
AND I SAID, SUPPOSE YOU PUT THE
LIGHT INSIDE THE BODY THAT YOU
CAN DO THROUGH THE SKIN OR IN
SOME OTHER WAY.
AND THEN I SAY THE DISINFECTANT,
AND ACTED OUT IN A MINUTE, ONE
MINUTE.
AND IS THERE A WAY THAT WE CAN
DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
BY INJECTION INSIDE OR ALMOST A
CLEANING, THAT WOULD ALSO BE
INTERESTING TO CHECK.
SO EVEN AFTER THE MEDICAL CHECK.
>> Jesse: HERE’S THE PRESIDENT
REACTING TO THE MEDIA COVERAGE
SAYING HE IS NOT ENCOURAGING
ANYONE TO INJECT DISINFECTANT.
>> I WAS ASKING A QUESTION
SARCASTICALLY TO REPORTERS LIKE
YOU JUST TO SEE WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN.
NOW, DISINFECTANT FOR DOING THIS
MAY BE ON THE HANDS WOULD WORK.
WHEN THEY SAY THAT SOMETHING
WILL LAST THREE OR FOUR HOURS OR
SIX HOURS, BUT IF THE SUN IS OUT
OR THEY USE DISINFECTANT, IT
GOES AWAY IN LESS THAN A MINUTE.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, GREG.
I WATCH THIS AS IT CAME IN.
AND TO ME I DID NOT THINK HE WAS
BEING SARCASTIC.
IT LOOKED LIKE HE WAS SPENT
BORROWING IDEAS TO KNOCK THIS
THING OUT, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Greg: THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
WAYS TO LOOK AT THIS.
THEY ARE TWO THINGS THAT DON’T
MATTER AND ONE THAT DOES.
WAS IT OFF-THE-CUFF?
MAYBE, DOESN’T MATTER.
WAS IT SARCASM?
MAYBE, MAYBE NOT, DOES NOT
MATTER.
WHAT MATTERS IS THAT ANYONE
ACTUALLY BELIEVES THAT HE WAS
SAYING YOU SHOULD INJECT CLOROX
INTO PEOPLE, I MEAN, 1,000 DAYS
WITH TRUMP AS PRESIDENT AND WE
STILL HAVE AN ENTIRE INDUSTRY
MOBILIZED BY AN OFFHAND COMMENT.
HOW CAN ANY ADULT BELIEVE
SERIOUSLY BELIEVE THAT HE WAS
SAYING, HEY, PEOPLE SHOULD
INJECT CLOROX INTO THEIR BODY?
I MEAN, I KEPT WANTING TO
BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
PRE-EXISTING CONDITION TO
BELIEVE THE WORST ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT COMES OUT OF
TRUMP’S MOUTH, OR THE WORST
ABOUT EVERYBODY, REALLY.
I WOULD CHALLENGE THE MEDIA ONE
DAY TO LOOK AT SOMEBODY THEY
DON’T LIKE AND TRY TO ASSUME THE
BEST OF THEIR COMMENTS.
BUT I CANNOT BELIEVE THAT THEY
ARE ACTUALLY INTERVIEWING
EXPERTS.
SO, JUST TELL US, YOU CAN’T PUT
CLOROX INJECTED INTO YOUR BODY,
CAN YOU?
THIS IS ACTUALLY A NEW CYCLE.
OTHER STUFF IS GOING ON.
THIS IS HILARIOUS.
>> Jesse: I THINK THAT LYSOL
RELEASED A STATEMENT ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
JUAN, CAN YOU TRY TO BE FAIR?
YOU CANNOT BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT
WAS TELLING AMERICANS TO PUT
LEACH DOWN THEIR THROATS?
>> Juan: I HOPE NOT.
THAT’S WHAT I HEARD.
BUT I HOPE NOT.
IT MAKES NO SENSE, JESSE.
WHEN YOU SAID SPIT BAWLING, I
THINK YOU ARE RIGHT.
HE WAS RIFFING.
TODAY I THOUGHT HE TRY TO GET
OFF THE HOOK SAYING THAT HE WAS
BEING SARCASTIC.
THE PRESS SECRETARY SAID HE WAS
TAKEN OUT OF CONTEXT.
WELL, YOU CAN’T DO BOTH.
YOU HAVE TO PICK ONE.
AND THE THING IS, FOR ME TO SEE
HIM AT THE WHITE HOUSE IN THE
BRIEFING ROOM, SAYING SOMETHING
LIKE THAT, AND BELIEVE ME, THERE
WAS NO DOUBT YOU QUESTION.
THERE IS NO QUESTION AT ALL.
HE WAS JUST RIFFING, SPIT
BAWLING, HE JUST CAME OUT WITH
THE STUFF.
AND I THINK THAT TO SOME EXTENT,
YOU KNOW, FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
LISTENING TO HIM, I THINK THAT
IT IS UPSETTING AND DANGEROUS.
I JUST COMING IN OH, GREG SAYS
IT IS THE MEDIA.
BUT I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT
NEEDS TO BE PRESIDENTIAL AND
SAYING SOMETHING LIKE THAT, I
THINK THAT IT INVITES DISASTER.
>> Jesse: I AM HAVING DR. BIRX
ON MY WEEKEND SHOW, AND I WAS
LIKE, ARE YOU THERE, DO YOU
THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT WOULD
SAY ANYTHING DANGEROUS?
AND SHE SAID NO, HE WAS PROBABLY
THINKING OUT LOUD AND TRYING TO
COME UP WITH A GOOD IDEA.
AND TALKING TO THE PERSON AT
DHS.
>> Emily: IT’S HOW HEATHER
WILL NUMBER ONE WAS KILLED IN
"HEATHER’S," IT’S PRETTY OBVIOUS
THAT YOU SHOULD NOT DRINK BLEACH
OR THE LIKE.
LOS ANGELES AND MARYLAND HAVE
REPORTED THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
INUNDATED WITH CALLS, THEIR
PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCIES OF PEOPLE
INQUIRING ABOUT IT.
SO WHO KNOWS, BUT I THINK IT IS
SAFE TO ASSUME, UNFORTUNATELY
NOW THAT HE HAS TO CLARIFY ALL
OF HIS COMMENTS.
AND I DO THINK, HOWEVER, THE
PRESIDENT’S CONTINUED COMMENTS
AT THE BRIEFINGS UNDENIABLY
OFFER FATHER FOR HIS DETRACTORS
TO ATTACK AND DISCUSS IT IN THE
NEW CYCLE.
IT’S UP TO HIS TEAM WHETHER THEY
WILL MAKE THE CALL THAT IT’S NO
LONGER BENEFITING HIM.
>> Jesse: I STILL THINK IT
CONTINUES TO BENEFIT HIM, BUT
OBVIOUSLY THAT WAS A BIG
DISTRACTION, DANA, FROM SOME
PRETTY IMPORTANT NEWS FROM THE
DHS DIRECTOR OF SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY THAT OUTSIDE IN THE
LIKE, OR IN HIGH TEMPERATURES,
HIGH HUMIDITY, IT HAS A VERY
DETRIMENTAL EFFECT ON THE VIRUS.
>> Dana: YES, ONE THING,
SETTING ASIDE ALL OF THIS AND US
THINKING ABOUT THE SCIENCE AND
DEVELOPMENTS, THERE ARE SOME
COMPANIES AND SCIENTISTS THAT
ARE WORKING ON USING UV LIGHT AS
A DISINFECTANT FOR LIKE AN
AIRPLANE, FOR EXAMPLE, OR
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE WOULD GO
THROUGH, WHEN YOU’RE GOING
THROUGH THE TSA LINE, AND IF
THAT IS A DEVELOPMENT THAT COULD
ACTUALLY WORK, THAT WOULD BE A
GOOD THING, NOT JUST IN REGARDS
TO CORONAVIRUS, BUT FOR A WHOLE
HOST OF THINGS.
SO HOPEFULLY IF THAT DEVELOPMENT
ACTUALLY DOES COME TO PASS,
NOBODY IS MAKING FUN OF THOSE
SCIENTISTS, BECAUSE WE DO WANT
TO HAVE A DEVELOPMENT HERE.
AND IT WOULD ALSO SAY, IF I HAD
TO TAKE A CHOICE THAT HE WAS OUT
OF CONTEXT, WHICH HE WAS.
OR SARCASTIC, I WOULD SAY TAKEN
OUT OF CONTEXT.
BUT THE MEDIA IS ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR THAT.
IT’S ONE THING ABOUT THE MEDIA,
BUT IT’S ANOTHER ONE, I THINK
THE SOCIAL MEDIA, LIKE THE
INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE AND
IMMEDIATELY THERE IS MEMES.
THAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN IF YOU
DON’T HAVE A REALLY TIGHT
ANNOUNCEMENT.
BUT IT’S NOT WHO HE IS.
HE WAS NOT SUGGESTING THAT
PEOPLE DRINK BLEACH, BUT THE
COMPANIES WERE NOT PUTTING OUT
STATEMENTS BECAUSE OF WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID.
IF SOMETHING DOESN’T, THEY WILL
GET SUED.
SO THAT’S ANOTHER REASON THAT
YOU DO THAT, BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT YOUR OWN SITUATION
WHEN THE MEDIA COMES AFTER YOU
NEXT, BECAUSE SOMEBODY DECIDES
TO DO SOMETHING WITH YOUR
PRODUCT THAT WAS INAPPROPRIATE.
>> Greg: I NOTICED IN ONE OF
THE COMPANY IS RESPONDING TO
REPORTERS ASKING ABOUT IT.
IT WAS LIKE THE REPORTERS WENT
TO THE HEAD MEDIA SAYING, CAN
YOU, WHATEVER, CAN YOU -- THIS
IS UNSAFE, SO IT WAS THE NEXT
LAYER OF THE STORY.
WE ALSO HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
WHEN DONALD TRUMP TALKED ABOUT
SUNLIGHT AND TALKED ABOUT THE
SUMMER AND THE SEASONS CHANGING,
THAT WAS DECLARED AS
NONSCIENTIFIC.
REMEMBER?
AM AM I JUST REMEMBERING THAT?
>> Dana: WHAT IS STRANGE AS
WHITE IS SINGAPORE SEEING AN
UPTICK?
I FEEL LIKE EVERY DAY, LIKE
TODAY WE GOT SIX NEW SYMPTOMS
FROM THE CDC.
WE FIND OUT MORE THAT THERE IS
ACTUALLY AN INCREASE IN
SINGAPORE.
IT’S HOT AND HUMID THERE.
I FEEL LIKE WE STILL DON’T HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION, AND WE ARE
FIVE WEEKS INTO THIS AND WE ALL
WANT TO GET BACK TO WORK AND
BACK TO THE CITY.
>> Greg: EVERYONE COULD BE
INDOORS.